après une décennie de luttes et même d'
affrontements sérieux les forains ont
décidé d'enterrer la hache de guerre
dans le conflit qui les opposait à
l'état et aux principales villes de
l'hexagone
aujourd'hui ils signent un accord qu'ils
qualifient eux-mêmes d'historique accord
qui leur donne droit de cité c'est
important
reportage philippe gassot didier
deshamps à la porte de pantin comme
ailleurs les forains ne sont pas des
gens du matin à 7 heures seuls les
enfants des écoles passent ils coupent
par les manèges pour se rendre à la
piscine
il en profite aussi pour rêver ils
seront suivis de près cette fois par les
gens du voyage qui se sont levés tôt
exceptionnellement car la journée est
historique on se souviendra dans le
monde de la fête du 15 décembre 1993
on n'a pas hésité à sortir les costumes
des chemises floors ce qui donne au
maître des lieux de faussaires de par
ses biens après les luttes que nous
l'avons menée pendant de nombreuses
années c'est l'aboutissement de plus de
ces luttes la reconnaissance de notre
profession et c'est une grande victoire
pour
profession ces dix ans du 10 ans de
combat on peut dire dix ans à
interpeller les pouvoirs publics de
manière à ce que la fête ait droit de
cité la fête foraine et droit de cité
cette victoire est donc garantir le
droit à certains emplacements ville fini
les négociations au jour le jour et au
coup par coup à 7 minutes les gens du
voyage sont reconnus à paris et c'est un
début d'autres villes de france suivront
les forains deviennent des français
comme les autres
on oublie pas pour autant que par
moments ça a été dur
ça vous rappelle quoi ces dix années de
l'état
une belle cicatrice sur la tête qui est
du franches de leur première entrée dans
jardin dès ce matin les forains ont
délaissé le manche de pioche et les
tuileries pour l'hôtel de ville la paix
est signé le cheval de manège en est le
gage
les forains ne viennent jamais l'ema
vida